9:00 ON "AMERICA'S NEWSROOM"
AND AGAIN ON OUTNUMBERED AT
NOON.
TUCKER IS NEXT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR KIM
JONG UN HAS PROPOSED A
FACE-TO-FACE MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT HIS
COUNTRY'S NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT JOHN
ROBERTS HAS BEEN ON THIS
STORY AND HE HAS DETAILS AT
THIS HOUR.
JOHN?
>> THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
MOMENT IN HISTORY, TUCKER,
JUST FOR THE VERY FACT THAT
WE HEARD FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE TONIGHT THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS AGREED TO MEET
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF NORTH
KOREA.
I MEAN, NOBODY THOUGHT THAT
ANYTHING LIKE THIS COULD
EVER HAPPEN UNLESS IT WAS
UNDER THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY
OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THIS IS KIND OF FROM A
BEGINNING LEVEL.
YOU KNOW, KIM JONG UN HAD
TALKS WITH SOUTH KOREAN
OFFICIALS EARLIER THIS WEEK.
THOSE SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS
CAME TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY TO SAY THAT KIM IS
COMMITTED TO THE DO YOU
NUCLEARIZATION OF THE NORTH
KOREAN PENINSULA AND HE HELD
OUT THAT OLIVE BRANCH FOR A
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO HAS SAID
IN THE PAST MANY TIMES HE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH
KIM AGREED U THIS IS AIMING
TOWARD THE DENUCLEARIZATION
OF THE NORTH KOREAN
PENINSULA.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT FREEZING
NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR
PROGRAM AS HAS HAPPENED SOME
TIMES IN THE PAST ONLY TO
WATCH THEM CHEAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING IT
CLEAR THAT HE WANTS KIM JONG
UN TO GIVE UP HIS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
A STATEMENT FROM THE PRESS
SECRETARY JUST A SHORT TIME
AGO WILL PASS ALONG TO YOU,
PRESIDENT TRUMP GREATLY
APPRECIATES THE NICE WORDS
OF THE SOUTH KOREAN
DELEGATES AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP MOON.
HE WILL ACCEPT THE
INVITATION TO MEET WITH KIM
JONG UN AT A PLACE AND TIME
TO BE DETERMINED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH
KOREA.
IN THE MEANTIME, ALL
SANCTIONS AND MAXIMUM
PRESSURE MUST REMAIN.
THE QUESTION OF WHERE IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT GOING
TO GO TO PYONGYANG IN NORTH
KOREA TO MEET WITH KIM JONG
UN.
>> I DON'T EXPECT THAT KIM
JONG UN WOULD COME TO THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE HE
MIGHT FEAR THAT HE WILL BE
THROWN IN AN AMERICAN JAIL
AND NEVER SEE THE LIGHT OF
DAY EVER AGAIN.
NOT THAT THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IT MAY BE THAT THEY CHOOSE
POTENTIALLY SOUTH KOREA
RIGHT THERE ALONG THE
BORDER, WHICH WILL BE THE
SITE OF THE TALKS BETWEEN
SOUTH KOREA'S PRESIDENT AND
KIM JONG UN LATER IN MAY OR
MAYBE IT'S A THIRD COUNTRY.
SOME NEUTRAL COUNTRY
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD
WHERE EVERYONE CAN MEET.
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT
IN THE WHITE HOUSE JUST
WALKING US THROUGH THAT IN A
CONFERENCE CALL RIGHT NOW.
BUT, CHUNG EUI-YONG ADVISOR
SAID IN A STATEMENT OUTSIDE
THE WHITE HOUSE HERE IT WAS
DUE TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PROGRAM OF MAXIMUM PRESSURE
THAT NORTH KOREA CAME TO THE
TABLE.
THEY SAID THAT WHILE KIM IS
COMMITTED TO THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA, HE ALSO
UNDERSTANDS THE JOINT
MILITARY EXERCISES BETWEEN
SOUTH KOREA AND THE UNITED
STATES MUST CONTINUE.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS YOU
WILL REMEMBER, TUCKER, CAME
UNDER AN EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF CRITICISM FOR HIS
TOUGH-MINDED APPROACH TOWARD
NORTH KOREA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE SAYING
HE WANTED TO START A WAR
WITH THE NORTH.
IT WOULD SEEM THAT EXACTLY
THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED.
RATHER THAN THE MISSILES
FLYING, IT LOOKS LIKE THERE
WILL BE TALKS.
AND IT REALLY IS, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT EVERYWHERE WE WERE
UP UNTIL THIS POINT, AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT IN
HISTORY.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: IT'S ASTOUNDING.
JOHN, WAS THERE ANY MENTION
OF THE ROLE, IF ANY, THAT
>> I THINK THAT THIS WAS
VERY MUCH A BEHIND THE
SCENES SORT OF THING.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PROGRAM OF MAXIMUM PRESSURE,
THAT WASN'T JUST THE UNITED
STATES.
IT WAS THE UNITED STATES AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER COUNTRIES,
FIRST AND FOREMOST AMONG
THEM, CHINA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PUSHED
XI PING TIME AND TIME AGAIN
TO INCREASE THE SANCTIONS,
TO PUT THE SQUEEZE ON NORTH
KOREAN BANKS, TO NOT ALLOW
WORKERS IN NORTH KOREA --
NORTH KOREAN WORKERS IN
CHINA TO SEND MONEY BACK TO
NORTH KOREA.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MUCH CHINA DID IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.
IT SEEMED LIKE IT WAS
LIMITED.
BUT AT THIS MOMENT, IT
APPEARS LIKE IT MAY HAVE
BEEN ENOUGH.
SO WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS
GOES.
NOBODY IS UNDER ANY
ALLUSIONS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT KIM JONG UN,
THEY MIGHT THINK THAT HE IS
SINCERE, BUT NOBODY THINKS
THAT HE IS NOT POTENTIALLY
PLAYING FAST AND LOOSE HERE.
WE HAD JOHN BOLTON THE
FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR ON
AIR SAYING HE THINKS THEY
ARE JUST TRYING TO BUY TIME
SO THEY CAN COMPLETE THEIR
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PROGRAM.
THEN THEY HAVE A VERY BIG
BARGAINING CHIP.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THIS
OPTIMISTICALLY HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT THIS MAY BE THE OPENING
THAT THE UNITED STATES HAS
WAITED FOR AND TRIED FOR FOR
AN AWFULLY LONG TIME.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNEXPECTED
TO SAY THE LEAST.
JOHN ROBERTS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: HARRY IS A NORTH
KOREA EXPERT AND DIRECTOR OF
DEFENSE STUDIES AT THE
CENTER FOR THE NATIONAL
INTEREST AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
HARRY, I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY,
ANY OF THE GENIUSES RUNNING
OUR FOREIGN POLICY IN
WASHINGTON PREDICTED
ANYTHING LIKE.
THIS I CERTAINLY DIDN'T.
THAT'S FOR CERTAIN.
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT THERE WAS
A BETTER CHANCE WE WOULD BE
AT NUCLEAR WAR WITH NORTH
KOREA THAN THERE WOULD BE
PEACE TALKS.
THERE IS SOMETHING WE ARE
MISSING, TUCKER THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT.
SOUTH KOREAN PRESS ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO CAME OUT WITH
REPORTS THAT WERE
FASCINATING.
THEY ACTUALLY SPECULATED
THAT NORTH KOREA WAS
ACTUALLY ON THE EDGE OF
FINANCIAL BANKRUPTCY.
BY OCTOBER, THEIR FOREIGN
EXCHANGE RESERVES ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE
EXHAUSTED AND THEIR DOLLAR
RESERVES ARE GOING TO BE
EXHAUSTED.
SO THAT MEANS NORTH KOREA IS
ESSENTIALLY BANKRUPT.
YOU CAN'T BUILD A LOT OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND A LOT OF
MISSILES WHEN YOU HAVE NO
MONEY TO DO IT TO PAY ALL
THE DIFFERENT SPIES AND
PEOPLE TO BRING THOSE
MATERIALS BACK.
YOU CAN'T FEED YOUR PEOPLE
THAT WAY.
SO I DO THINK THE NORTH
KOREANS MIGHT BE TRYING TO
BUY SOME TIME HERE.
I ALSO THINK THAT KIM JONG
UN'S NEW FOUND PRAGMATISM
THERE MIGHT BE A BIGGER
REASON FOR IT.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS KIM PLEDGED THAT
NORTH KOREAN WILL REFRAIN
FROM ANY FURTHER NUCLEAR OR
MISSILE TEST.
>> AS LONG AS WE'RE TALKING
THAT'S THE OTHER CAVEAT TO
THAT POINT.
AS LONG AS BOTH SIDES ARE
NEGOTIATING AND WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE SOMETHING
OUT, THEN THEY WON'T TEST
THERE IS A BIGGER POINT TO
ALL OF THIS.
WHAT I WOULD URGE PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO DO, MEET WITH KIM
JONG UN, THROW THE HAIL
MARY.
THESE THINGS CAN HAPPEN AND
WORK OUT.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THAT
WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
CANNOT DO, TUCKER IS, GIVE
HIM ANY BRIBES.
GIVE HIM ANY ECONOMIC
INCENTIVES.
THE NORTH KOREANS HAVE TRIED
THE TABLE THAT WOULD BE THE
WRONG MOVE AND THAT WOULD BE
THE A MISTAKE.
>> Tucker: HUH.
WHAT IS THE GAMUT?
CONTINUED PRESSURE IN THE
WORDS OF SOUTH KOREA.
>> TEST THE INTENTIONS.
MAYBE THEY'RE SINCERE.
MAYBE THEY ARE WILLING TO
COME TO THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
SOMETHING HERE.
THE NORTH KOREANS, TIME IS
AGAINST THEM.
THEIR ECONOMY IS A DISASTER.
IT'S WORTH SOMETHING LIKE
$14 BILLION.
SOUTH KOREA'S IS WORTH
SOMETHING LIKE 1.2 TRILLION.
SOME DAY THE NORTH KOREAN
STATE WILL COLLAPSE.
AND I THINK KIM REALIZES
THIS.
SO THIS MAY BE HISTORIC
MOMENT.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE
THIS BEFORE PROBABLY IN
DECADES.
SO I THINK TRUMP HAS TO
EXPLORE IT.
>> Tucker: HE MAY BE THE ONE
PRESIDENT WHO WOULD MEET
WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
LEADER.
IS HE GOING TO STOP ON HIS
WAY IN OSLO TO GET THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE?
>> HE SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
PEACE PRIZE.
IF HE CLOSE THE ULTIMATE
DEAL OF A LIFETIME YOU GIVE
THAT MAN THE NOBEL PRIZE.
NO QUESTION.
>> Tucker: THE CHANCES OF
THAT ARE RIGHT AROUND ZERO,
I THINK.
>> THERE MAY BE --
>> Tucker: OF GETTING THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
GAVE IT TO OBAMA FOR GETTING
>> HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
TRUMP HAS --
>> Tucker: WHAT HAPPENS JUST
TO GAME THIS OUT A LITTLE
BIT AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
SPECULATIVE.
THE END GAME, OF COURSE, IS
REUNIFICATION THAT KOREA IS
BECOMING ONE COUNTRY AGAIN.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN FOR
EVERYONE ELSE?
>> MEANS A LOT OF GOOD AND A
LOT OF BAD.
THE BAD IS THE TOUGHEST
PART.
THE COST TO REUNIFY NORTH
KOREA WITH SOUTH KOREA IS
PROBABLY SOMETHING LIKE
$10 TRILLION.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT HAVING
TO BUILD ROADS, BRINGS, TAKE
CARE OF THEIR PEOPLE.
THE ECONOMICS OF THAT WOULD
BE TOTALLY INSANE.
PLUS, YOU WOULD HAVE CHINA
WHAT A STRONG KOREA WOULD
MEAN FOR THE REGION.
JUST THINKING THAT THROUGH
IS JUST ASTRONOMICAL.
>> Tucker: HUH.
AND CHINA AND JAPAN WOULD
NOT BE IF FAVOR.
>> JAPAN CONVINCE THEM IN
THE LONG TERM AND CHINA ONE
OF THEIR BIGGEST FEARS.